in demonstrator there are many secrets
you might not know even if you read the
entire manga let alone just watch the
anime so in this video I thought it
would be fun to count down 101
interesting Demon's hair secrets that
many people and especially anime
Watchers would have no idea about if you
like the idea of such a demon Sarah
video I want to see more like it like
maybe for specific characters because
the bonus material for this series is
very rich then child the demiser with it
and slay that like button until it goes
up in fireworks and let me know what
specific character you'd like to see
covered next in the comments if you
haven't yet join the demon slang fan by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demon Center videos and updates and with
the new demonstrator season coming out
in April so it's just around the corner
you can expect a lot more of those and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all secret number one
one of my favorite Secrets because I
like the ship so much is that the love
hashira's green socks were given to her
by serpent hashira obanai iguro although
mitsui can sometimes act like she's in
love with everyone which I guess is a
love hashira kind of thing to do as this
video goes on it'll become more and more
apparent that iguro is the most special
to her especially in the Romantic sense
number two on the topic of clothing you
might ask why mitsuri wears her uniform
in such a revealing way when the other
female demon Slayers don't well in truth
all female uniforms were designed to
look like mitsuris the demonstrator
Uniform Tailor called masao Maeda
designed all the female uniforms to be
similarly revealing so it's not
surprising that he's been nicknamed the
four-eyed creep in the series however
shinobu burned her uniform and gave oil
in matches so that aoi and kanal could
burn theirs too this explains why they
don't have uniforms like mitsuris
mitsuri ultimately continued to wear her
uniform as is despite being initially
embarrassed about it so if you want to
get super specific about it mitsuri is
actually following the uniform protocol
more than the other girls number three
mitsuri actually created her own
breathing style Called Love breathing
and it's derived from flame breathing
her Discovery is documented in the
stories of flame and water bonus volume
where mitsuri was still being mentored
by kyojuro rengoku and kyojuro for his
part was nahashra yet at least until he
defeated the former lower Moon too
number four in a bonus manga page the
mangaka whose Avatar takes the form of
an alligator with glasses tells us that
mitsuri's hair starts pink and turns
green because mitsuri loves Sakura Mochi
The Story Goes she ate so much of it
that her hair changed to reflect the
color of the Sakura Mochi number 5.
mitsuri has the biggest appetite out of
all the hashira she can eat 100 sticks
of Dongo that is one big Dango Family
and because of how much she eats we're
told her food expenses are ridiculously
high talking about love that transcends
all iguro and Mitri actually make a
cameo appearance in chapter 137 of a
completely different series called
tonikaki Kawaii a romantic comedy I love
seeing the impact not only of Demon
Slayer on other works but even of the
love between these two specific
characters definitely one of my favorite
ships ever number seven so the fact that
igoro loved mitsuri was pretty obvious
when you take into account how jealous
he got about tanjura being close with
her but the fact that mitsuri loved
iguro romantically was not as clear
until her confession after the muzon
fight however in the second fan book
it's revealed that she did love him long
before that but was unable to confess
her feelings because the trauma from her
past marriage interviews held her back
number eight the second fan book reveals
the level of openness of different
characters specifically of the hashira
mitsuris was 90 so very open let's see
if you can guess who will have the
lowest level of openness in the comments
out of all the hashira number nine there
were two popularity polls for Demon's
air and mitsuriga 12th Place in both of
them number 10 on to iguro the serpent
hashira sometimes called the snake
hashira his snake is called kaburamaru
but more importantly he does not
consider kaburamaru to be a pet right
other he considers him to be his friend
number 11 after iguro's death kaburamaru
is entrusted to kanau by windhasha
sanami you might think that it's
interesting that sanami made the
decision of who the snake would end up
with but the two meaning iguro and
sanami were actually quite close in the
second fan book The hashra are each
asked how they feel about the other
hashira while iguro hates water
hashiragiu he says that sanami is a
friend he gets along with in turn sonami
also says he hates guiyu and that he
gets along with iguro the most
interestingly enough Sunami says he
doesn't like mitsuri much which could be
another reason iguro likes him because
he's clearly not a romantic rival number
12 in contrast to his love mitsuri iguro
has the smallest appetite of the hashira
and has no problem going three days
without eating number 13 despite not
liking to eat iguro does like to watch
mitsuri eat and seeing her happily eat
makes him work up an appetite and he
ends up eating more than usual number
14. in the first popularity poll igoro
ranked 26th Place but in the second
popularity poll he shot up to 8th Place
positioning him comfortably within the
top 10 most popular characters in the
entire series number 15. in contrast to
mitsuri iguro is not physically strong
despite being a hashira the mangaka
called him a little weak the only hashra
he could beat in arm wrestling is insect
hashira shinobu however keep in mind
this is physical strength alone that's
being taken into account and doesn't
reflect how well he'd do in an actual
death battle number 16 quite often in
Shonen manga you'll find references to
Japanese myths and folklore and that's
the case with iguru as well when his
mouth covering comes off we see that he
has scars on both ends of his mouth we
know the snake demon did this to him so
he'd look more like her but rather than
being a joker why so serious reference
for Japanese readers this would be a nod
to the Japanese legend of kuchisake the
spirit also covers her face with
something like iguro does with the
bandages the legend goes that she asks
potential victims if she looks pretty if
they say no she ends them if they say
yes then she reveals the corners of her
mouth which are slit ear to ear like
igoros she asks them if she looks pretty
again if they say no she ends them if
they say yes she similarly disfigures
their mouth but there is a way out if
you describe her as average or if you
distract her with money or hard candies
then you can escape with your life and
without looking like the Joker number
17. obanai's level of openness is as one
would expect lower than mitsuris at 60
percent however honestly it's still
higher than I expected and not even
close to the least open person number
18. due to his upbringing where he was
surrounded by female relatives who
severely mistreated him not to mention
the female snake demon iguru developed a
fear and even hatred towards females
this actually got worse believe it or
not when he saw the weak resolve of a
lot of female demon Slayers of course
mitsuri is the exception though she is
the first and only woman he ever found
to be beautiful so he's the opposite of
the Sanji type character who falls Head
Over Heels forever every attractive
woman number 19 in the kimetsu academy
spin-off where characters from Demon
Slayer are put in a modern context
specifically in a school iguro is a
chemistry teacher and his fear of women
in the original manifests itself as an
allergy to women in this story however
even in this alternate universe he still
finds himself drawn to mitsuri an art
college student and he asks about her
all the time in Ali's Restaurant number
20. alright now that I've discussed one
of my favorite couples for an adequate
period of time we can now move on to
Tundra the protagonists of the series
Tundra ranked first in the first
popularity poll but surprisingly fell to
fourth place in the second and don't
worry we'll get to who the most popular
character was by the end of the series
soon number 21 in the bonus Pages it's
revealed that Tundra's pen pals include
sakonji senjuro the kurdisms from the
Entertainment District tengen and guiyu
however giyu never writes back number 22
even if tanjiro inherited the dance of
the fire god and the sun breathing from
his father father we learn in the first
fan book that Tundra inherited his
insanely hard forehead from his mother
so it's nice to know that both of his
parents in a sense help him in battle
number 23 in kimetsu Academy despite
being dubbed the most polite in school
tanjiro is known as a boy who
continuously violates the rules also his
family owns a bakery number 24. tendra
is such a pure and honest guy that he
can't keep a straight face when he's
lying number 25. in contrast to tanjiro
the mangakas protagonist before Tundra
was very different she published Hai
niwa no zigzag in 2015. zigzag can be
found translated online and follows a
character who removes curses which
sounds nice enough but he actually
wanted to kill people through curses
before because he could make a lot of
money that way but then he got cursed
himself so that he could never kill or
use his power for personal gain he sort
of forced to be a good guy against his
will by the curse an interesting concept
and one very different from tanjiro in
Demon Slayer unlike Tundra 2 zigzag
protagonist punishes people who do bad
things and is described as a poison that
will eradicate evil number 26 the very
first manga that the demon Sarah mangaka
published was called kagarigari and it
was published in 2013. this one shot was
a sort of prototype for Demon's air and
contained many ideas that would find
their way into Demon Slayer the
characters of yushiro and Tamayo are
present so is another character that
dresses similarly to The Demon King of
Pop muzon however notably our main
characters are missing number 27
speaking of main characters let's talk
about one of my favorites zenitsu
zenitsu ranked second in the first
popularity poll and you may have guessed
it first in the second popularity poll
Not only was I into the most popular
character by the end of the series he
also ranked 29th Place in promised
Neverland's 2020 popularity poll 44
people voted for him even though he
wasn't supposed to even be an option and
as we'll get into there are characters
who ranked well below that in the Demon
Slayer popularity poll so it's crazy how
popular science is and how much it
spread across different series not just
Demon Slayer number 28 By the time
demonstrator and zaitu is the only one
of the trio to do two things that have
only been done by hashira one he created
a new and original breathing style form
with his flaming Thunder God attack
something yiu did with that Khan second
he defeated an upper Moon all on his own
something also done by missed hashira
muichiro if you didn't know one of the
requirements of becoming a hashira is to
beat a demon Moon and that can be a
lower Moon too it doesn't have to be an
upper Moon so to say that zaitsu earned
the hasha title is misleading because he
went above and beyond what it takes
which is why in my books it's completely
fine to call Sunny to the Thunder
hashira or as they say in the
demonstrate world for Thunder using
hashira the rumble hashira number 29 in
some bonus materials given in the
complete box set of Demon Slayer it is
revealed that zenitsu loves sweets and
expensive foods like eels as a result he
would have been fat if he wasn't a
swordsman number 30 Saints who surname
agatsuma means and I quote my wife and
quote in Japanese which seems fitting
for a guy constantly obsessed with women
and specifically with finding a wife of
his own number 31 zaitsu's kasugai Crow
is the only Sparrow to appear in the
series and pass the kasugai crow test it
is the only kasugai crow that can't talk
its family was killed by demons so he
wanted to help the demon slaying cause
too yes even zaritsu Sparrow has a
meaningful backstory although nickname
Chun Taro we're told his actual name is
ukogi number 32 time for some inosuke
inosuke for his part ranked fifth in the
first popularity poll and sixth in the
second number 33 the Ino and inosuke's
first name is reminiscent of the first
part of the Japanese word for boar
inoshishi A fitting detail for the boar
mask wearing Slayer number 34. in the
first fan book it's noted that inosuke
used bores but also bears and wolves as
references when creating Beast breathing
his very own breathing style he joins
mitsuri enchinobu in the characters who
created their own breathing Styles Club
number 35 the first fanbook reveals that
inoski is hated by both the uniform
makers and by the swordsmiths this is
because he always tears apart the top of
his uniform and purposely chips the
swords that the swordsmiths make for him
right in front of their eyes number 36
something that you might not have picked
up on is that inosuke and nezuku
actually have a really close
relationship in the second fan book it's
revealed that inosuke respects nezuko
like a mother figure because she was
always kind to him and never yelled at
him for being different he reports
things that happen to him to her
although the relationship is purely
platonic their close Bond can still get
on zanitu's nerves number 37 in the same
fan book it's revealed that when nezuko
went to visit kanau and aoi once a month
inosuke would go with her we can imagine
these trips helped inosuke develop a
romantic relationship the final chapter
of the series features their great
grants on Alba hashibira number 38 the
second fan book also notes that although
aoi doesn't smile often inosuke was able
to make her laugh a lot by doing
unexpected things since this was
arguably the least focused on romantic
relationship of the main Trio in the
manga I'm glad to see the mangaka giving
the relationship special attention in
the bonus material number 39 while 72's
kasugai Crow is a sparrow in those case
is an actual Crow but the relationship
is no less interesting the crow mostly
hides from inosuke because inosuke
almost ate his kasugai Crow not once not
twice but 18 different times I think
this is an especially hilarious detail I
must say number 40 even in kimetsu
Academy inosuke was raised by boers and
as a result his unique story is featured
on TV it's also notable that he doesn't
wear shoes number 41 time to discuss
nazuko she came in third place in the
first popularity poll and dropped all
the way down to 11th in the second thus
she was no longer the most popular
female character in the series we'll get
to who that was in a bit though number
42 before she became a demon one of
nesco's Brothers Takeo asked her what
her ideal man would be like she said he
would be like a rook referencing the
shogi piece that can move any number of
squares horizontally or vertically this
brings zanitsu's unique fighting style
in mind which is characterized by fast
straight movements thus it seems these
two were always faded to end up together
number 43 we are used to seeing nezuko
with her bamboo muzzle but in kimetsu
Academy the bamboo muzzles are replaced
with baguettes probably from her
family's bakery number 44 we've finally
arrived at the hashira with the lowest
level of openness if you guessed it
right let me know water hashira giyu his
level of openness is 30 number 45 gee
ranked fourth place in the first
popularity poll and second place in the
second popularity poll number 42 6. Q is
the only character aside from rengoku
with his own spin-off manga his bonus
story follows him and shinobu on a
mission after he's already met Tanja
nezuko giyu and shinobu grab a bite
afterwards and Geo uncharacteristically
cracks a smile the audience doesn't see
it but it seems to freak out shinobu
number 47 one of the most popular ships
and Demon Slayer is gyux shinobu even
though it doesn't really pan out however
when asked what he thinks of the other
hashira giyu says that shinobu talks to
him often he sees positive
characteristics in her like her
earnestness and hard-working nature and
he even shows concern when he says she
looks unwell at times although the two
don't end up together one wonders if
they might have given different less
demon-filled circumstances Q also
doesn't seem to be interested in mitsuri
since he says about her that she's
revealing too much skin number 48. in
the second fan book it's revealed that
after gyu's Hari was almost torn to
shreds because of the muzon fight nezuko
was the one who managed to restore most
of it for you Gil was so touched and
grateful that he gave her many gifts
like kimonos and western clothes as
usual Geo's actors were misunderstood
and zenitsu began to consider him a
potential love rival number 49 although
you had trouble making friends and there
are a lot of memes about him having no
friends he does become friends with
sound hashira tengen uzui after the
final battle when tangent's child is
born gee was even allowed to hold the
baby number 50. in kimeto Academy gyo is
a gym teacher AKA a PE teacher number 51
at the halfway point we move on to
shinobu shinobu's surname contains the
reading for butterfly which seems rather
fitting for the insect hashira number 52
shinobu ranked sixth in the first
popularity poll and fifth in the second
making her the most popular female
character by the end of the series
number 53 in the first fan book it's
pointed out that shinobu and mitsuri
despite having very different
personalities get along quite well due
to them being the only two female
following big siskana's death mitsuri
even taught shinobu Western cooking
number 54. part of shinobu's Epic plan
to defeat upper Moon 2 Doma was to be
absorbed by the upper Moon originally
shinobu was stated to have 70 times the
lethal amount of Wisteria poison in her
body however in the volume Edition the
mangaka corrected this to 700 times the
lethal amount thus it's no wonder the
poison had such a profound effect on
upper Moon 2 Doma number 55. in the
second fan book it's revealed that
shinobu had a pet goldfish called Fugu
Fugu however translates to puffer fish
in Japanese the one that's eaten after
some very poisonous Parts have been
taken out a fitting name for the also
poison filled shinobu's pet number 56
shinobu's thoughts on the other hashira
are also very revealing for guiyu she
wishes he'd talk a bit more suggesting
she wishes he'd open up more to her for
stone hashtra gilme she says she
respects him from the bottom of her
heart if you didn't know know after
their parents were killed by a demon
they Kana and shinobu were saved in the
nick of time by gyome they decided to
follow in his demon slaying footsteps so
that they could help prevent others from
going through what they went through
lastly and perhaps most interestingly
I'll mention what she said about sanami
that went hashira namely that whenever
they meet each other he asks if she's
doing okay this seems pretty sweet and
out of character for someone like the
hot-headed angry son of me but it's
actually because sonami was so close to
Kanai shinobu's older sister before she
died and we'll get into that more later
number 57 last shinobu fact is that
chernobyl's level of openness was 85
percent which is definitely higher than
I would have expected number 58 on to
Bad Boy sanami the wind hashira sanami's
surname has immortality River in it
which seems fitting for a guy that just
won't die no matter how many injuries
you throw at him number 59 sonomi ranked
15th Place in the first popularity poll
but he shot up and broke into that top
10 during the second one where he came
in Ninth Place number 60. in the first
fan book it's revealed that the reason
sonami keeps his uniform always open
unlike most people is because he is
proud of his muscles number 61. sonomi
shares the exact same height and weight
as muzon they are both 179 centimeters
or 5 feet and 10 and a half inches tall
and they both weigh 75 kilograms or 165
pounds number 62 sanami's level of
openness is 60 percent making him less
open than shinobu but twice as open as
GUI number 63 when describing how he
feels toward the other hashira sanami
said that he talks to shinobu now and
then since she's kind of his little
sister as I mentioned he says sound
hashir attack and acts like an older
brother he unlike iguro doesn't like
mitsuri much since her to use his words
idiotic side is hard to deal with
however like iguro he hates guiyu and he
comments that he's sick and tired of
gyu's on not like you guys attitude he
likes rangoku since he's a good guy and
as mentioned he gets along with igoro
the best a pretty cool under the radar
Bromance that you might not notice
number 64. in kimetsuo Academy sanami is
a math teacher even if he can't quite
keep his whole shirt open he does still
keep his collar open and he still has
all his scars making him look like the
most gangster math teacher you've ever
seen you might be entertained by the
fact that once a student told him that
nobody needs math in the future and
sonami responded by throwing him out of
the window and surprise surprise he
talks a lot to Kane Sensei number 65 as
revealed when gome talked about his
views on sanami the Wind hashra likes
Kanai the former flower hashra and
shinobu's older sister this is of course
why he talks to her a lot in the cometsu
academy world and why he asks kana's
younger sister if she's okay now and
then it's interesting that Best Buds
iguro and sanami both fell for a female
hashira number 66. now on to Canal
tsuyuri Kano actually chose her own last
name aoi in nosuke's future wife wanted
a sister so badly that she fiercely
pestered Connell to choose her last name
kanzaki unfortunately to no avail number
67 Kano ranked 8th in the first
popularity poll and fell down to 10th
place in the second popularity poll by
the end of the series she was the second
highest ranking female character after
her big sis figure shinobu number 68. in
the first fan book it's revealed that
kano's actual birthday was not known so
Kanai and shinobu made the day they
adopted her her birthday May 19th number
69 kano's coined that she previously
used to flip to make life decisions was
given to her by Kanai and she keeps the
coin in a memory box that was also given
to her by big siskanai number 70. on the
cover of demonster volume 18 Kano is
featured however there's a mistake that
most won't catch take a second and see
if you can spot what's wrong if you said
that the mangaka accidentally Drew her
sword on the right side of her waist
when it's supposed to be on the left
side good job you'd be right the mangaka
gotoge made a statement apologizing for
this mistake after the volume's release
number 71 on to the legend himself flame
hashira kyojuro Ren Goku kyojuro's
surname rengoku actually translates to
Purgatory which is why the ninth form of
flame breathing is also called rengoku
number 72 kyojuro ranked seventh in both
the first and second popularity poll
meaning he was consistently a top 10
popular character despite the fact that
he passed on relatively early in the
series no small feat and it's a
testament to how well the mangaka wrote
his character and his death as well
number 73 kojuro loved sumo wrestling
number 74. sweet potatoes were kyojiro's
favorite food so much so that he'd
scream out tasty or delicious every time
he put one in his mouth number 75 in the
first handbook it stated that unlike
shinobu kyojiro was never allowed to
have a pet because his father hated
animals man as if we didn't have enough
reasons to dislike Kyoto's father number
76 in kyojuro's spin-off in the stories
of water and Flame volume a kid asked
couldn't Goku why his hair is weird and
kojo responds maybe my ancestors ate too
much deep fried shrimp number 77 when
the Mugen Train movie came out the
mangaka released a bonus manga one shot
following rengoku's first mission
hopefully she does similar things down
the line with the other hashira however
in this one kojiro succeeded in
defeating a flute demon that used sound
to disorient his victims rengoku
ruptured his own eardrums so he'd be
unaffected once again showing us how
much of a Chad he is number 78 when
asked what he thought about the other
hashira JoJo was overwhelmingly positive
the most quote unquote negative he got
was saying that Geo's voice was so small
that it was difficult to hear what he
had to say hopefully that's not lasting
damage from the eardrum rupturing and
after complimenting Tangen he happened
to mention that he slightly has too many
wives a hilarious line but an
informative one because now we know that
three wives is a bit too much for the
flame hashira number 79 kyojuro has the
highest level of openness at 95 percent
number 80. in kimetsu Academy kyojuro is
a history teacher not surprisingly he's
passionate about teaching and history
and his students love him number 81
although Kano is the only known tsuguko
in the series it's specifically revealed
that in kyotira's case he doesn't have
one because his training is too hard and
they end up running away that speaks
well of mitsuri who was his student
during the events that take place in the
stories of water and Flame spin-off
number 82. in the second fan book The
hashira were ranked by running speed
from fastest to slowest were tengen
sanami gome shinobu kyojuro giyu iguro
tokito and and mitsuri notably though a
caveat was given that obanai iguro ran
in zigzags like a snake rather than in a
straight line so it's quite likely he
would have ranked higher if he sprinted
in a straight line while mitsuri ran
after she finished eating number 83 out
of the hashira the ones that stand out
with abnormally large Heights are tang
and uzui at six feet six inches and
gentle giant and stone hashiragyome at 7
feet and two and a half inches shinobu
is the shortest at 4 feet 11 and a half
inches number 84 when the hasha were
ranked in terms of who would be the
strongest in an arm wrestling
competition the list went from strongest
to weakest yomei tengen kyojuro Sanam
mitsuri muichiro iguro and chinobu it
was noted that kyojuro sanamigu and
mitsuri were close enough that it would
be a close match between any two of them
number 85. now let's focus on muichiro
tokito a bit the Mist hashiras since he
will be playing a major role in the
upcoming swordsmith Village season
muichiro's first name contains the
meeting for quote unquote nothingness in
it and his surname contains the meaning
for quote-unquote transparent which is
fitting for our missed hashira who has
at least in the beginning forgotten his
past number 86 muichiro has one of the
craziest jumps in terms of popularity in
the first popularity poll he ranked in
29th Place in the second one he jumped
all the way to third place so you can
expect to like muichiro a lot more after
this upcoming season number 87 in the
series tangit has singled muichiro out
along with gyome for being especially
talented in bonus materials kyotro even
said muichiro is more talented than
kyotra was at his age number 88
muichiro's level of openness is the
second lowest at 40 percent number 89 in
the first fan book it's revealed that
muichiro purposely wears oversized and
loose clothes in order to disorient his
enemies it's hard to see his Limbs and
Joints so it's hard harder for them to
predict his movements I love how many
details there are like this for the
hashira and how each of the hashira are
so fleshed out and unique number 90 when
asked his opinion of the other hashira
muichiro compared them all to animals
except for guiyu who he described as a
decorative object and oh man GUI really
gets picked on a lot in this series
anyways shinobu was a swallow bird tang
in a monkey iguro a wild cat gomei is
like a bear then Goku is like an owl
mitsuri is like a pink colored chick and
sonomi is like a wolf I don't know if I
agree with muichiro on his views here
but I find the idea of picking an animal
to describe every hashira interesting so
let me know what you would pick for each
one and of course do gyu and muichiro as
well while you're at it number 91. now
on to the strongest hashira Stone
hashirag you may already know that he's
blind which is why he has no pupils but
in the second fan book it's explained
that he wasn't born blind he was blinded
due to a fever he had when he was a
child number 92 gyome is the only
hashira besides shinobu and muichiro to
have a personal connection to an upper
moon for muichiro upper Moon one is his
ancestor for shinobu upper Moon 2 killed
her sister and for gyome kaigaku the new
upper Moon sixth used to be an orphan
gilme looked after before he betrayed
yomei and the other orphans to a demon
kaigaku would then go on to be zaitu's
thunder-breathing Senpai and like an
older brother figure 2 him before he'd
eventually betray zanitsu and their
Mentor as well by becoming a demon to me
I think higaku is probably the most
hateable character in the entire series
let me know if you agree or if you would
pick someone else number 93 in the first
fan book it's revealed that gyomi loves
cats a trait he shares with love hashira
mitsuri number 94 although I chose not
to include voice acting facts in this
video for the most part it must be said
that yomei shares the same Japanese and
English voice actor as Kion from The
Melancholy of Haru isuzumia one of the
first anime I ever watched and one that
will always hold a special place in my
nostalgic heart number 95 yomei's
thoughts on the other hashira are a gold
mine he's very observant and drops gems
like shinobu seems to enjoy talking to
guiyu mitsuri seems to like iguro
suddenly likes Kanai Gio seems happy
talking with chernobyu and igura seems
to be in love with mitsuri I love how he
just points out every ship we need to
know about among the hashira for us
Number 96 Gomez love of openness is
among the highest at 90 percent number
97 in kimeto Academy Gomez a Civics
teacher and a first year homeroom
teacher since he's so muscular students
are often scared of him at first but
then they see that all of his belongings
have cats on them and they soon realize
he's a nice person who likes cats number
98 and of course we need some Ninja
Secrets up in here so it's tang in time
the sound hashira ranked 37th in the
first popularity poll so he was less
popular demons wasn't promised Neverland
not very popular at all but climbed up
all the way to a respectable 13th Place
for the second popularity poll number 99
in the first fan book tengen's ninja
family's practice of polygamy is
explained at 15 a boy must have three
wives the head of the clan will choose
the wives and they do take chemistry
into account when they pick number 100
this is my first ever video where I got
into a three-digit Factor secret so
let's take a second to celebrate that by
Smashing that like button and thus
triggering the YouTube fireworks that
would be a very flashy thing to do and
you know tengen would appreciate it but
back to tengen and in the second fan
book some dark stuff is revealed for
instance it's explained that tengen had
eight siblings so there were nine of
them in total three died due to how hard
their father's training was the
remaining six children were made to
compete in a death battle of sorts while
wearing masks due to the masks they
didn't know they were fighting each
other Peg and killed two of his brothers
before he realized what was happening
one of tangen's Brothers killed another
two brothers and so it was just them two
in the end however Tangen was disgusted
by his father's ways and left the clan
with his wives after this Tangen would
have the habit of saying he's going to
hell but he stopped saying it because it
upset his wife so much and I love how
they all had very different reactions
makio got angry hinatsuru cried and Suma
wait for it bit him that biting part
specifically gets me every time number
101 in kimetsuo Academy tengen is an art
teacher which is more flashy than you
think he does stuff like yells art is an
explosion and then blows up some
Dynamite as someone who completed
Teachers College I have no idea how this
dude made it through notably he also
used to be a gang leader and his
students even call him Gangsta Sensei
and that's 101 Demon Slayer secrets you
probably didn't know one for every
Dalmatian and now if you want to get
even deeper into the hidden and
sometimes times a very dark world of
Demon Slayer you don't want to miss my
demon Sarah Iceberg video link on screen
right now and in the description